slightly more positive tune in the
westminster playground on day two of
this campaign david cameron saying that
a conservative government over five
years could create would create two
million new jobs in britain a rather
punchy projection for any political
party to make it's not governments that
create jobs after all its businesses
but for the conservatives it's if you
like the sharp end of a whole bunch of
policies that make up their long-term
economic plan but they're quite dreary
things like deficit reduction and
spending cuts and austerity and perhaps
people want to hear something that's a
bit more sunlight than the grey
austerity we've had over the past five
years
certainly
their basis for this number is that last
time five years ago the obr projected
about a million jobs and they've got 1.9
million they're projecting a million
more over the next five years and so the
conservatives argue well let's just
double it again they do have some
credibility to spend on this the sort of
claims they made in the 2010 election
exactly five years ago on jobs were
ridiculed at the time frankly we were
just coming out of recession remember
but they've been more than achieved so
they're trying to if you like
crystallize everything about the
conservative economic plan around an
output of people
in a job and millions more of people
in a job now labour obviously argue hang
on a minute the jobs that have been
created over the past five years well
they're zero hours they're part-time
they're self-employed they're not real
jobs or many of them are not real jobs
and underpinning all of it is uh pay
freezes and engine cuts and all that
sort of stuff
the big truth though about this is that
both parties aren't really telling the
whole story the low pay and high jobs
are intrinsically connected uh they're
two sides of the same coin you go to
factories that have been kept open car
factories they've created loads more
jobs or maintained jobs and you notice
that they had three or four years of pay
freezes they're the flip side of each
other but the labour party don't want to
admit that pay freezes and pay
restraints have helped job creation and
the conservatives won't say that the
jobs miracle is built on low pay so
we're not getting the whole story from
either major party